hi everyone welcome and thank you for
joining us for today's seminar regarding
microrna biomarker discovery with
respect to technologies workflows and
data analysis
my name is jonathan schaefer and i'm
senior scientist in product development
at kyogen
before we continue i will give our
standard disclaimer that the products
described in this seminar are intended
for molecular biology applications
and these products are not intended for
the diagnosis prevention or treatment of
a disease
for today's agenda i want to cover the
following information we'll begin with a
background regarding biomarkers microrna
and sample selection we'll spend the
bulk of the time today discussing micron
isolation technologies quantification
technologies as well as a circulating
micron and biomarker discovery
experiment
we'll then discuss data analysis
recommendations
and finish up with a summary of kaijan's
product offerings and filled any
questions that you may have at that time
so feel free to write in any questions
that you have to the q and a box and at
the end i'll read through these and
we'll answer these live
so let's begin and start with the
question what is a biomarker a biomarker
is a characteristic that is objectively
measured and evaluated as an indicator
of normal biologic processes pathogenic
processes or pharmacologic responses to
a therapeutic intervention
in essence it's a proxy for any of these
and a biomarker can be a characteristic
such as a presence of a circulating
antibody abnormal blood pressure
blood cell counts or electrolytes also
it could be a distinct histological
indicator through immunocytochemistry or
microscopy
abnormal liver function markers it could
also be the presence of a muscle injury
protein say in response to a heart
attack
elevated kidney markers or the gene
status or gene expression status
gene status you could have a somatic
mutation in the tumor or for a gene
expression status you can have
overexpression of an oncogene
now the method for analyzing your
biomarker is linked to the specific
biomarker
and for the presence of an antibody you
can use an elisa
obviously for blood pressure you can
bp you can choose a
blood pressure cuff
microscopy for histological indicators
various biofluid assays
and for uh
the gene expression status real-time pcr
next generation sequencing microarray
etc and for somatic mutation qpcr or if
you're in a discovery mode next
generation sequencing
and so a lot of what we're going to
discuss today is uh
revolving around cancer biomarkers and
cancer biomarkers can be several
different types first off a prognostic
indicator
answering the question is this likely to
develop cancer
also a cancer biomarker can be a
diagnostic nature answering the question
what type of cancer is it
also and in the realm of collectively
personalized medicine a cancer biomarker
can be predictive
it can be a pharmacodynamic or it can be
a recurrence biomarker answering the
questions is this the optimal drug for
my cancer what's the optimal disc for my
body and will this cancer return and i
want these in personalized medicine
simply because in response to both the
tumor in addition to responding to the
tumor type and the drug this response
will also be uh
dependent on the individual's genetic
makeup
let's briefly discuss a non-invasive
biomarker and in order to use a
biomarker for diagnostics the sample
material must be as easy to obtain as
possible and from the realm of easy to
difficult you have a uranus or
saliva sample
a drop of blood like those a diabetic
patient would extract
a blood sample taken by a doctor
and more invasive would be a csf sample
and most invasive would be obviously a
surgical biopsy
so all things being equal if you're
looking at a non-invasive versus an
invasive biomarker you would like to go
the route of a non-invasive but again
everything has its place including the
non-invasive and the invasive biomarkers
uh over the past few years a lot has
revolved around blood samples
and blood samples are made up of a
cellular and acellular component and
nucleic acid acids extracellular matrix
components and lipids can be extracted
and in addition you can simply look at
the blood cells for the presence of
abnormal cells abnormal cell counts and
also for stem cells or circulating tumor
cells for example
and collectively any of these components
of blood can be biomarkers in and of
themselves or you can combine assays
assessing multiple components to derive
a biomarker panel
now let's shift gears from biomarker and
discuss micro rna
micro microrna are approximately 21
nucleotides small non-coding rnas and
here we have the canonical pathway of
microrna biogenesis
micrornas are first transcribed by rna
pol 2 is a long primary transcript which
may contain more than one micro rna
in the nucleus the primary rnas are
processed to hairpin like precursor
micrornas by the rna s3 like enzyme
teresa
the pre-micrornas are then exported to
the cytosol by exporting thyme
or they're further processed by dicer to
mature micrornas
the mature micrornas are unwound and one
is incorporated into risk and micrornas
with high homology to their target mrna
can lead to mrna cleavage and microns
with imperfect base pairing to their
target mrna can lead to translational
repression and or mrna degradation and
this is the case usually observed in
animal systems
let's briefly to highlight some of the
key findings of microrna over the past
20 years
and it's nice to see the progression in
a very small condensed time frame
you have the initial discovery of
micrornas particularly the uh
first characterized microrna by victor
ambrose and colleagues lynn fort rnai
being characterized by fire in mello and
c elegans in 1998 that led to their 2006
nobel prize
after discovery you then have
characterization of srn as a tool
including large numbers of micrornas
being discovered
and at this point you're looking at
there are probably hundreds of micrornas
now as a mirror-based version 21
discovery of micrornas continues to date
as there are more than 2500 annotated
micrornas in human alone and more than
35 000 annotated for all species
included in mere base
then you have the first disease
implications uh associated with microrna
and cancer by the cartilage lab
you have micronus being used as
diagnostics and one of the key findings
was micrornas serum biomarker in 2008
you have to decipher any of the
mechanisms of
how micrornas act
as well as the therapeutic implications
of micrornas as well
so you can see from discovery through
srna is a tool to the first disease
implications diagnostics mechanisms and
therapy
in 20 years or so the micro rna
exhibits itself is a natural phenomenon
discovery tool and potential biomarker
why should you quantify micrornas
so if you exclusively look at the number
of annotated micrornas in mir base this
reflects the interest in the field
you have the initial entries as a
mir-based version one and as of mere
based version 21 i've mentioned already
that as of june 2014 there are more than
35 000 annotated mature micrornas
now this number alone doesn't simply
mean that
there's interest in the field that
microns have a very very broad sweeping
role in biology and changes in microrna
can be correlated with gene expression
changes in development differentiation
signal transduction infection aging and
disease
and uh
looking at how expression analysis
weaves into this the micron expression
analysis is the foundation for these
discoveries
if you look at the role of microneed
cancer diagnosis micrornas are being
used to differentiate cancer tissue from
normal tissue
to identify tissues of origin for
cancers of unknown primaries
to distinguish tumor subtypes to predict
cancer predisposition and also as
minimally invasive biomarkers for the
early detection of cancers
and this is a very hot area at this time
if you look at circulating micro rna
biomarkers in the press there are
certainly no shortage of candidates this
is simply a truncated list from one
publication but we have micrornas being
described to be decreased in gastric
cancer
decreased in non-small cell lung
carcinoma increased in breast cancer
increased in colorectal cancer
so on and so forth and these also
possess both their agnostic and
prognostic value
so now let's discuss the type of type of
samples that you will use in microrna
biomarker discovery
these can be your serum
plasma cerebrospinal fluid for
circulating biomarkers and you can also
use your standard cell ffpe samples
urine and potentially any fluid that
relates to your particular disease of
interest
and your analytes can be your cell free
microrna mrna or dna and for today's
talk we will be focusing on microrna
so here's a question what is blood blood
is your red blood cells white blood
cells platelets and other cells such as
circulating tumor cells serum as your
blood separation of your liquid phase
post clotting and plasma is separation
over your liquid phase without clotting
now in plasma high levels of nucleuses
are present and as a result of this you
would say that freely circulating
nucleic acids should be rapidly degraded
however
somewhat maybe surprisingly stable
nucleic acids can be detected in serum
and plasma meaning that they're
protected by one mechanism or another
and how are my micrornas stable in
circulation over time it's an involving
story so micrornas can be protected in
exosomes and other micro vesicles
complex with ako2
protected by hdl
or complex with an other quote unquote
protective protein
in addition i've included some
references here at the bottom
for your further reading
let's take a closer look at exosomes
with exosomes and micro vesicles it's
truly the cargo that matters
exosomes are 50 to 200 nanometers small
vesicles excreted by all cells and
exogens are found in all biofluids for
example blood
and exosomes contain stable rnas such as
mrnas micrornas and other non-coding
rnas as well as dna and protein and this
is all protected from degradation by a
lipid bilayer
and the contents of an exosome are
specifically packaged and
are used as a mechanism of both local
and distant cellular communication
there are many potential uses for
exosomes as an analyte that hold promise
for both disease detection and
monitoring
exosomes are involved with tumor
profiling they can be surrogate
diagnostic markers for biopsy profiling
and also hold possible utility to screen
populations
elevated levels of accidents have been
determined in blood of patients with
late stage ovarian cancer and lung
cancer holding promise for prognosis and
therapeutic monitoring
exosomes can be used to determine
molecular signatures indicative of
responses versus non-responses to
therapy when you're profiling patients
exosomes have therapeutic implications
simply because you can deliver an
exosome payload to specific cells
and lastly exosomes are less of a needle
in a haystack there are 10 to 10 to 12
to 10 to the 12th exosomes per ml plasma
while there are only 1 to 10 circulating
tumor cells per ml of blood and this has
impact for potential clinical utility
so looking a little bit closer at
exosomes and the role of liquid biopsies
let's take a micro rna example
so there are various publications and
this is certainly not an except
exhaustive list where the exosample
micron expression parallels originating
tumor cell expression
and
this is minimally invasive simply
because you can use exosome microrna
profiling in the absence of tissue to
accurately reflect the tumor's profile
and the take home message is that
exosomal load assessment and exosomal
molecular profiling hold great promise
for both disease detection and
monitoring
now that we've spent a few slides on
exosomes let's ask this question should
you only look at exosomes and the answer
is no
well
sometimes
and i say it that way because
potentially 90 percent of micrornas in
circulation are present in a
non-membrane
bound form consistent with a
ribonucleoprotein complex
meaning they're outside of exosomes at
the same time though analyzing the
exosome fraction could maximize your
signal-to-noise ratio of a potential
biomarker providing better sensitivity
now let's move into the variety of
technology so i want to introduce some
technologies that you'll use and we'll
spend maybe 15 20 slides or so on this
before we move into a this biomarker
discovery experiment so explain the
tools and then i'll show you how to use
the tools
so first off for total rna isolation
from body fluids you would use the
micrornas serum plasma kit this is for
purification of circulating rna
from plasma serum cerebrospinal fluid
urine saliva etc virtually all biofluids
can be used in conjunction with the
microarrangy serum plasma kit
some of the highlights of the kit are
that it includes a synthetic rna control
for normalization
it provides you with a minimal evolution
volume and the rna is highly pure for
all downstream applications
as you can guess it's easy and robust
and can also be automated
and our one recommendation when working
with serum and plasma is when possible
avoid heparinized plasma simply because
heparin is a potent reverse
transcription inhibitor
however if you can't avoid heparin eye
sample just let me know if kaijan we're
always exploring new avenues to as
access new samples so we certainly have
a solution for you if you have
heparinized plasma
so at the end contact me
jonathan.shaverkyjen.com and we can set
up a solution for you
now back to task here with the micro and
easy serum plasma kit we have the
workflow on the left you add kaizo you
add your kaizo lysis reagent add
chloroform and separate your phases
and you add ethanol to the aqueous phase
and bind bind this to a column wash it
and elute your ultrapure rna
the next kit i would like to discuss is
for exosome purification and total rna
isolation from serum and plasma this is
the exo-r and ez serum plasma maxi kit
this specifically enriches for rna
contained in vesicles
you can quickly isolate purified total
rna from micro vesicles
and you can
efficiently isolate both mrna and
microrna from plasma and serum
and this kit also enables use of high
input volumes for sensitive detection of
low abundant transcripts so what is the
input range the input range is 200
microliters to 4 ml of serum or plasma
so if you look at how i um
xor and ez prep compares to an ultra
centrifugation prep
we have the following example so if you
use a scanning electron microscopy to
twenty thousand x magnification this
reveals higher purity with exo easy kit
both preparations contain your vesicle
shaped structures within an expected
size range however ultra centrifugation
you also have many smaller unidentified
structures that do not match the
expected size
and the exo easy column which is part of
the exo rnz kit you have intact vesicles
with the
with higher purity
here we have the workflow of the xor and
easy kit can be divided into three
phases
phase one is where you separate your
serum or plasma
phase two is then where you isolate your
exosomes
and phase three is where you isolate
your rna over a column very similar to
the micrornas serum plasma kit
now the greatest advantage of this in in
addition to higher purity is also the
time
so that microvesicle isolation can occur
in 20 minutes and rna isolation takes a
little more than half an hour so
collectively from sample to isolated rna
you can have isolated rna from exosomes
in less than one hour
so i told one of the organizers here let
me take my advertisement here for coke
so let's continue on so now let's
discuss circulating microrna biomarker
discovery
and with this you will use the
microscript pcr system
this is a real-time pcr-based approach
system and workflow is as follows you
isolate rna
perform reverse transcription
prepare your pcr premix
load your pcr arrays or individual
primer assays perform real-time pcr and
analyze your data
and let's go into more detail of the
components of the microscript pcr system
so for for reverse transcription you
will use the microscript 2rt kit
and the kit is built with your
particular biological questions in mind
if you're interested in biogenesis
studies perhaps where which precursor
microrna your mature micrornas derive
from and also what mrna your microrn is
potentially interacting with you would
want to synthesize cdna using high flex
buffer which allows you to detect all
rna molecules from one c dna synthesis
now for mature micronic quantification
profiling and biomarker discovery we've
developed the specific solution for this
type of studies you would synthesize
cdna using high spec buffer high spec
buffer is a patent pending technology
for the specific detection of mature
micrornas
the reverse transcription of longer rnas
that sometimes give you a
background cross reactivity signal when
profiling mature micrornas is highly
suppressed leaving you with a very ultra
clean mature micron specific signal
now looking more at the second component
of the microscope pcr system this is the
microscope micro rna pcr arrays
basically these are individual mature
microrna primer assays that are
pre-dried and pcr plates these are
pre-formatted single-use plates with wet
lab verified assays
and just as an overview we offer arrays
for microgram profiling
targeted microneme profiling or
bioinformatic driven profiling and i'll
go over these in more detail in the
coming slides
but the greatest advantage of these
are that you simply prep your pcr
reaction mix load your plate and run
your real-time experiment there's no
individual pipetting of primers
so i mentioned that the assays are
verified so what does assay validation
mean to you it means a total quality
total commitment to quality
so our workflows as follows the primers
are designed using a state-of-the-art
proprietary algorithm and following this
all primer designs are individually
bench validated in product development
to ensure negligible background signal
single specific pcr products optimal
dynamic range and optimal reaction
efficiency basically everything that you
come to expect out of a primer we test
it
any primer that then files fails
validation is redesigned and re-tested
and if the primer fails again we don't
offer it for sale
also just as a note all lots of
microscript pcr arrays are individually
quality controlled
so let's discuss the variety of options
you have now we have the mirbase
profiler microscript microrna pcr array
and what this enables is to you to
choose your micrognome
we have coverage for human and mouse
through mirror based version 21 with
over 2400 assays for human alone
over 1700 for mouse and we also have
coverage for rat dog rhesus macaque cow
and our relative latest species of
interest is horse
some of the benefits are again that the
assays are 100 validated and the best
advantage to you is that the solution is
completely scalable
you can choose as many places you want
of what your question is that you want
to answer and also how your fits in with
your budget so if you want to be on the
cutting edge of discovery you can
profile the version 21 microgram however
if you want to profile it only the tried
and true original micrornas you can
choose to only profile the version 16
microgram and cut down your number of
plates so it's truly scalable based off
of your type of experiment that you want
to do
now you may say
are the
most recently annotated mature micrornas
even expressed and we did this
experiment where we profiled a liver
tissue sample of that was a pool of 10
healthy male liver tissues across our
2400 assays
and as you can see from assay 1 through
2400 we have the raw ct values
included
and as you can guess that even the most
recently annotated mature micrornas are
also exhibiting signal meaning that they
may be relevant so what we do is we
offer as many assays as we can possibly
validate and let you decide how it fits
in with your experiment and whether they
are relevant for your experiment of
interest
and this is just a comparison of
coverage that we have in comparison to
other leading vendors that we have
coverage through mirror-based version 21
for microscript while the other two
vendors that i have listed have coverage
through approximately mere base version
10.
looking at this in one more manner the
same liver tissue profiling experiment
for each plate the express micrornas
were determined and this is a ct with a
limit of detection of 35
and as you can see you have
approximately 300 in plate 1 and around
200 for plates 2 through 5 and 300 plus
4.6 now this is micrornas included in
their base version 19 version 20 and 21
and as you can guess that's quite a lot
that are actually expressed
also note mirror base sorry
plate 7 is actually a partially filled
plate
and on the right we have the plate
median and plate mean for each of the
particular plates and beyond plate 1
which
giving their due they're the original
tried and true micrornas plates two
through seven all have approximately the
same meat and medium mean and median so
when you move beyond the original
micrornas
take a great notice of these because
they may be waiting to be discovered for
the next uh great biomarker discovery
let's take a look at our targeted
micrognome profiling our targeted
microderm profiling blends
bioinformatics with our leading content
the mi finder array collects the 372
best expressed and best characterized
micro rnas into one array
the serum and plasma blends in-house
profiling experiments we've done with
our bank of content assays
where we include the 372
best expressed micrornas in serum and
plasma the cancer pathway finder
collects the 372 micrornas most broadly
associated with cancer into one array
and the liver mi finder is another one
where we've blended in-house
wet bench experiments with our content
and these profile the 372 best express
micro rnas in liver tissue
and the last type of content is our
bioinformatic driven profiling we have
teams of scientists at kyogen that use
state-of-the-art bioinformatics and
manually curate literature to organize
micrornas into pre-formatted panels
based off of the hottest areas of
biology
and we have the mi finder that collects
the 84 best expressed and best
characterized micrornas into one array a
variety of cancer focused arrays a
hypoxia ray neurological development and
disease tumor suppressor micrornas and
also serum and plasma array now this
serum and plasma array collects the 84
micrornas most widely published to be
both present in circulation and
differentially expressed in response to
disease
now you may say well that's
all well and good that you have
identified these mic rnas that are the
hottest areas however this is nothing
that i'm interested in and the good news
is that these arrays are fully
customizable we can place you in contact
with a content development scientist and
have an array developed for your
specific needs
so let's take a look at the formats
in addition to our 96 well where this
contains 84 micrornas plus 12 controls
we have a 384 well 4x96 format and what
this is is essentially four copies of a
96 well
in a 384 well plate so if you have
access to a 3 4 well instrument and a 96
wall instrument please use the three
before windstrids simply because you can
either increase your workload for phone
or you can simply do your work all one
time and go home early in the day and i
like to tell people that it really
depends on the day of the week so monday
through thursday you can increase your
workload fourfold and on friday go home
early
in addition to these two 96 and 384 well
format we also have our 3d4 well hc
format that allows you to assess 372
micro micro rnas plus 12 controls
in addition we have pre-formatted
content for kyogen's rhetor g q
due to our variety of plastics and
formats we have compatibility with a
wide range of instruments from life
technologies bio-rad eppendorf roche
agilenter strategy tacara as well as
kyogen
and a couple more products i'd like to
introduce you to for limiting samples we
have the microscript preamp kit
and for a microgram profile you can use
as little as one nanogram of total rna
this is a highly multiplex pcr-based
preamp and is compatible with all
microscope arrays and individual primer
assays
and i'd already mentioned cells or
tissues one nanogram of total rna is the
limiting amount
and for fluids serum or plasma you can
use this with 50 microliters or less and
when you're working with your urine
cerebrospinal fluid or aqueous humor any
amount we recommend preamp and using
microscript preamp in a quote-unquote
verb sense when in doubt microscript
preamp we have customers all over the
world that are using preamp by default
and if you're unsure go ahead and
preempt it
now the last product i'd like to
introduce you to is a high throughput
micron expression profiling platform uh
the microscope microfluidics
and what we've done is that we've
developed a whole host of reagents that
are highly suited and highly optimized
to enable microrna profiling on the
fluidite biomark
and collectively this represents the
first complete system for micron
expression profiling on the biomark
now the take home message is that what's
the bottom line advantage it's a savings
of both time and money
if you're unfamiliar with a body mark
you can interrogate 96 samples at one
time each with 96 assays
leaving you with
9216 data points in one real-time pcr
run
so let's put this to the test and see
the savings
on the left if you have 96 samples and
384 assays and access to a 3d4-well
instrument you need to perform 96
real-time pcr runs
and at little more than two and a
quarter hours per 384 well plate you can
achieve your nearly 37 000 data points
in 216 hours roughly speaking 27 days
however if you use a fluid on biomark
you can achieve the same experiment with
only four chips
and very uh
generous here in time a very sorry very
conservative in time five hours per chip
you can achieve your 37 000 data points
in 20 hours which is a more manageable
two days
now let's quit talking about products
and discuss some of the workflows that
you'll use
workflow one would be when you're
working with pcr razor assays with
non-limiting amounts of cells tissue or
serum or plasma which is approximately
100 to 200 microliters
step one you convert your micro rna to
cdna step two you prepare your pcr
premix and aliquated across your array
step three you run your real time
experiment and step four you analyze
your data
workflow 2 is where you incorporate
preamp into your workflow this would be
again for limiting samples such as
limiting cells tissues small amounts of
serum or plasma perhaps 50 microliters
or less or other fluids
step one you convert your microrna to
cdna step two you perform your multiplex
preamp step three you prepare your pcr
premix and load your plate step four you
run your experiment step five you
analyze your data
workflow three is specific for serum and
plasma expression profiling
step one you collect your whole blood
and separate your serum or plasma and
tip one is if possible prep your sample
prep 100 to 200 microliters of your
sample for isolation
and tip two is though if you don't have
that type of input volume you can use
this kit to isolate rna from as little
as only five microliters of serum or
plasma
in step two once you have your sample
separated isolate rna using the micron
easy serum plasma kit
step 3 you perform reverse transcription
and step 4 perform preamp if your
experimental sample is of less than 50
microliters
and step 5 perform real-time pcr
and our array of recommendations
individual in addition to individual
primer assays are the mere based
profiler micromemory the ceramic plasma
384hc targeted micronum or the
bioinformatics serum and plasma array
step four is what you're working with
urine cerebrospinal fluid or other fluid
uh micron expression profiling
step one you collect and clarify your
sample and our recommendation is still
to start with 100 to 200 microliters but
this can be used with down to flat
microliters step two isolate your rna
using the micronesia serum plasma kit
plus spike in control
and the tip here is that the spiking
control enables calibration of your
samples based off of rna recovery and
we'll go over this in more detail a few
slides for now
step three perform reverse transcription
step four perform pre-amp by default and
step five perform real-time pcr
and our array recommendations in
addition to the mirror-based profiler
micronemo array are to use the
mirror-based profiler targeted micronet
array or the bioinformatic mi finder
array
now step five is a concept it's a
biomarker discovery workflow and we'll
go through this and then this is what
we're going to use then to discuss our
case for the day
so phase one is a where you determine
your expressed micrornas this is a
qualitative yes or no assessment
and the best way to do this is to use a
pooled sample profiling approach we
recommend incorporating up to 10 samples
per pool and do pools of both normal and
disease anywhere from two to four pools
per normal and per disease
and for this you want to use maximal
number of assays this can either be
microgram profiling with real time pcr
or you can use next generation
sequencing but in phase one we're simply
wanting to know what is present and
basically what we want to do is separate
the expressed from the non-expressed and
narrow our field to maximize both our
time and resources
phase two is then where you to use your
micrornas that were expressed in phase
one and determine your differentially
expressed micrornas and as a first set
of samples you can use any of the
samples that went into your pooled
samples to do individual profiling on
and for this you're only screening your
expressed micrornas from phase one
and in phase two you want to then
determine your differentially expressed
micrornas as well as your invariant
micrornas because the invariant
micrornas will be used in phase three
for data normalization
so in phase three this is your
classifier refinement this would be
further individual sample profiling only
on your differentially expressed
micrornas from phase two as well as some
invariant micrornas and i can't stress
it enough to include invariant micrornas
simply because there's nothing worse
than having to go back and redo
previous experiments because you weren't
able to identify a normalizer and our
recommendation is to include anywhere
from four to six invariant micrornas
just to hedge your bets that you have
actually selected in invariant microrna
that will remain invariant through your
entire sample population
so let's now discuss our case example
that we want to go over today this was a
liver toxicity microneed biomarker
project with dr james gear from
edinburgh university
and it revolved around acetaminophen
overdose and acetaminophen overdose
acetaminophen overdose is a common
poisoning worldwide and can cause acute
liver failure potentially resulting in
acute liver failure and death and the
scope of the collaboration was to
determine microneed markers of
acetaminophen poisoning and also to
distinguish acetaminophen poisoning from
other liver syndromes
and we followed the three-phase workflow
phase one we completed
where we identified 377
express micrornas and we narrowed the
list down from over 1800 we did this a
couple years ago so we were only using
mere base version 18 microgram
phase 2 where we determined our
differentially expressed micrornas we
found 92 micrornas of interest and
narrowed this down to 16 micrornas using
a classifier algorithm
phase 3 is ongoing and we're refining
the initial classifier including using
the assessment of blind samples
so let's go over this in more detail
so phase one again you're determining
express micrornas and essentially
surveying the microrna landscape
for this we started with 54 samples 27
controlled samples 27 liver injury
samples
we isolated rna with the micron easy
serum plasma kit and prepared 10 pull 4
pools 10 samples per
two controls two patient pools
and for expression profiling we use the
mirror-based profiler microderm array
mirror-based version 18 of 1800 assays
and for this we selected micrornas that
were present in all pools three pools
two pools and one pool and arrived at a
population of 377 assays so we narrowed
this down
from five 384 well plates to one 3d four
well plates simply by performing a
pulled approach
phase two we determined our
differentially expressed micrornas this
was a secondary screen of the individual
samples from phase one
again we used the 54 samples from phase
one that we profiled each one
individually
and we used the microscope pcr system
with 377 assays on the fluidized biomark
so we went through 54 samples
which roughly translates to 47 to sorry
to 40 000 data points in four days and
once we got more familiar with the fluid
on biomart system we've cut this down to
two days
and what we've identified is micrornas
that were differentially expressed
including ones that have been published
in association with acetaminophen
poisoning including mir 885 5p and mere
122 5p
and if you look at these on a volcano
plot where we plot forward change versus
p value we're able to see micrornas that
were
significantly
upregulated
phase three is the statistical power
phase and this would be where you're
further refining your classifier
algorithm
and you're screening a larger cohort of
affected individuals and you're
rearranging the differentially expressed
micrornas and looking across additional
samples
and you're continually continuing to
refine your classifier model and in the
bottom here this is the original 54
samples with the top 16 micrornas
now some important considerations when
performing a biomarker discovery
development experiment
our first recommendation is to be novel
initial whole micronim screenings can
leave you with unique signatures
and for this let's take this a
retrospectively what if question so what
if the group we worked with had only
profiled the first two plates roughly
760 768 mature micrornas
of the 92 differentially expressed they
would have only identified 64
and this would have translated to a 30
loss of data and actually they would
have lost two invariant micrornas
and don't underestimate the important
importance of this invariant rnas are
critical to the success of your
experiment without these you won't be
able to properly normalize your data
also five micrornas from the optimal 16
microrna signature would not have been
acid
including three of the top five
so moving on some other important
considerations are that you want to
verify your micro rna signature on naive
samples
and strong changes might be general
indicators or even be non-specific they
could be associated with other liver
disease or potentially even stress
markers
also note relatively weak changes might
add specificity and as you can guess
high levels of false positives or
undesirable are undesirable
but you also lastly want to ask the
question what's next
and with that you want to determine the
function of your microrna you can
revisit literature ingenuity ipa from
kaijen etc and potentially screen other
types of samples to help define
specificity as well as refine your
signature
so now let's discuss some data analysis
when working with serum and plasma
samples
serum and plasma samples have a unique
special case simply because the small
nuclear small nucleolar controller
panels does not exhibit robust
expression and should not be used as
normalization controls
and
small nuclear small nuclear rnas are
typically used for normalization when
working with cell and tissue samples but
these don't fit the bill when working
with serum and plasma
typically you see these type of ct
values well into the 30s or even
potentially not expressed
so you may say that what are my options
so step one we recommend calibrating
your sample using the c elegans mere
39-3 pct mean
and then normalizing using one of the
following two methods option one
normalize your ct to the ct mean of all
commonly expressed micrornas or option
two normalized to the cte mean of
inferior micrornas
so for this
step one
is that you want to calibrate your data
and you calibrate your data using the c
elegans mirror 39-3p
these are found on every pcr array and
what this acid detects is the micrornas
serum plasma spiking control
that has been added during sample prep
so if you look at an example here
sample 2 versus sample 1 all assays in
sample 2 appear to have a delayed ct
value
but at the same time c elegans mere 39-3
p also has a delayed ct value
and your conclusion is that you should
calibrate your samples because the c
elegans is indicating a differential
recovery
so how should you calibrate this you
should calibrate this by taking sample
two and subtracting three ct units from
each assay in sample two don't mix and
match be sure that you do this with each
micro rna and also indicate this when
you're writing this up for publication
that you've corrected for differential
recovery due to sample prep
and once you correct this you can see
that there's virtually no ct difference
from your 16 192 or 25 and instead of no
ct change from your 103 it was actually
more robust in sample two
and they're 21 instead of before ct
delay you're only looking at a one ct
delay
so once you've calibrated your data how
should you normalize this option one is
to normalize to the ct mean of expressed
micrornas
and this involves calculating the ct
mean for commonly expressed micrornas
and those are micrornas with a ct value
less than your limit of detection in all
of your assessed samples so to be
included in this
calibration sorry to be included in this
calculation it needs to be expressed in
all samples
option two is to normalize to the ct
mean of invariant micrornas
and this involves calculating the ct
mean for micrornas and choosing at least
four to six for this calculation
now we have a chart here commonly
expressed micrornas don't take this to
mean that these are invariantly
expressed invariant expressed micrornas
that can be used for all types of serum
and plasma samples is the holy grail a
lot of resources are being put into this
worldwide but there still is no
definable housekeeping microrna in
circulation
these are simply micrornas that you can
first look at to see if they're
invariantly expressed but the best case
is to always perform a broad microdome
profile or with pcr or mgs to determine
differentially and inferiorly express
micrornas
when you compare option one to option
two which should you choose when so
option one commonly expressed micrornas
choose this when you're working with a
micrognome panel a targeted micronim
panel or a pathway focused panel this
would be your large panels of micrornas
where the plate mean is truly indicative
of differences in rna amount
option two
is the invariant microrna panel and you
would choose this for small panel
screening or individual assays
as a note in this example the fold
regulation looks highly similar
irrespective of the method because
your results should be as independent of
your chosen normalization method as
possible
and as a second note for small panel
screening do not use the ct mean of
micrornas as this array is biased
meaning that your microrna assays
included on this array are not at random
so let's finish finish up with some
resources here we have a summary of
kaijan's microrna portfolio we have a
whole host of isolation technologies for
cells tissues ffpe tissues serum plasma
exosome isolation and enrichment of rna
and we also have pax gene solutions for
your blood types
and blood and tissue types
for quantification and profiling we
offer the microscope
pcr system and for functional analysis
we offer a host of transfection reagents
microrna mimics and inhibitors
now for biomarker discovery sometimes
your vision out exceeds the capacity of
your lab and i'd like to remind you
about kaiogen service core on multiple
continents that we have scientists
highly adept in total rna isolation real
time pcr and data analysis is included
as well
i'd like to remind you of the kai cube
for automated sample prep and the high
agility for automated pcr setup and the
rotogen queue for real time pcr
where can you find the products i
discussed today kaisen.com or kaijan.com
forward slash gene globe at gene globe
you'd simply type in your microrna of
interest and you receive a whole host of
products that are associated with it
with that let's take a look at the
questions i'd like to thank you for
attending today's seminar i truly
appreciate it i'd like to also encourage
you to write down my email
jonathan.schaefer kaijen.com
at any time feel free to write me any
questions that you have with respect to
micro rna or with respect to
products that you may need or even your
workflows
so with that let me take a look at the
questions
is there a first question we have is
there a any pharmaceutical products in
the market having micro rna
they are actively in development there
are molecular diagnostics being
associated with microrna
we have a second question here
so for
biomarker discovery workflow how many
samples do you recommend per pool
and this truly depends on your number of
initial samples but our recommendation
is up to 10 per pool maximally three
normal pools and three disease pools
okay we have another question here
can you elute exosomes from the exoec
membrane without using kaizo meaning
that we want to uh
isolate intact exosomes
and the answer is no not at this time
but we are
developing a solution for this
okay you mentioned data analysis
solution we have another question
and my question is uh
what is the cost of the data analysis
and the answer is that it's actually
free that it's freely available and can
be accessed through the web
and you can access it at kyogen.com
forward slash gene glib
sure
we have a question is there literature
resources available for the comparison
and normalization that you mentioned
so uh yes this is actually i can provide
you with this uh simply write down the
email jonathan.schafer kaijen.com and i
can point you to a particular paper from
uh the
group that was involved with the uh the
mikey guidelines and
these are methods of normalization that
are recommended recommended by this
group
okay we have a question about
heparinized plasma
and
the let's see
question is that their samples are
heparinized what are their options
okay so what we have is we have a
preliminary protocol where we basically
remediate the heparin and if you're
interested in this feel free to email me
and i will forward you the protocol
okay another question we have is um that
is it acceptable to normalize
exclusively to c elegans that has been
spiked into a serum prep
okay i see what you're saying so uh the
recommendation is to calibrate using the
c elegans and then normalize to the
plate mean or invariant microrna
normalization to cl against mere 39 only
accounts for differences due to sample
prep and doesn't have any biology tied
to it
one more question
would you please remind me what your
recommended starting volume is for serum
so our recommended starting volume is
200 microliters but if you incorporate
preamp into your workflow you can
isolate from down to five microliters
okay so that looks like that's it for
today again thank you everybody for
attending and feel free to write down my
email jonathan.shafer at kyogen.com
thanks everyone have a great day
you